autres pays européens autre stratégie
face à la crise sanitaire la suède qui
compte près de 400 morts du coup en un
virus si la moitié du globe et sous
cloche le pays scandinave refuse le
confinement clair ni quoi assis autour
d'un verre en terrasse au parc pour une
promenade entre amis ou encore improvisé
un match de foot
autant de choses qu'il est désormais
impossible de faire en france et
pourtant en suède ces activités sont
encore bel et bien autorisé compte tenu
de la logique que les autorités suivent
à savoir que nous ne pensions pas
pouvoir arrêter le virus mais plutôt
aplatir la courbe comme ils disent
je pense qu'il est juste d'appliquer des
réglementation moins stricte de les
maintenir pendant une plus longue
qu'ailleurs
le pays fait figure d'exception en
refusant d'appliquer la stratégie de
confinement si les autorités suédoises
conseils à la population de pratiquer la
distanciation sociale les écoles les
bars les cinémas ou encore les
restaurants restent ouverts seule
concession du royaume du nord
les rassemblements de plus de 50
personnes sont désormais interdits ainsi
que les visites extérieures dans les
ehpad
nous sommes en plein air cela fait du
bien au lieu de nous asseoir dans un
endroit bondé avec beaucoup de monde
[Musique]
nous verrons si le bus est plein retour
nous le prendrons pas et prendront un
taxi à la place nous faisons situation
par situation si la courbe des
contaminations resté relativement plate
jusqu'à lors certains épidémiologistes
commencent à tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
une attitude vivement critiquée par ses
voisins et notamment le danemark qui a
lui imposer un confinement strict